les joueuses de montigny le bretonneux
peuvent laisser éclater leur joie elles
viennent de signer leur troisième
victoire de la saison face au club
d'issy paris dans le championnat de
nationale 2 le match a été accroché
jusqu'à la fin 25 à 23 pour les
yvelinois ce qu'ils peuvent faire de
nous de l'équipe on a su rien lâcher
aller jusqu'au bout et décrocher cette
victoire donc énormément contente de
l'équipe je félicite mes joueuses sur
pour leur mental parce que chaque fois
en deuxième mi temps ils sortaient ils
sortent vraiment une grande partie ça
montre que mentalement on est là et il
reste beaucoup de travail à faire
trois victoires de suite c'est bien mais
ça continue il faut que ça continue
cette troisième victoire en quatre
matches discuter permet au club de
s'installer aux premières places
actuellement 3e de la poule 3 2l de
montigny le bretonneux est bien parti
pour remplir ses objectifs fixés en
début de saison on a un projet
aujourd'hui qui est d'évoluer au delà en
fait de ce qu'on évolue aujourd'hui et
je pense que oui ce serait une déception
ne pas y arriver cc c'est certain
maintenant on est
il faut aussi être clair avec tout ça on
est dans une poule très compliquée ou en
fait vous avez facilement cinq six clubs
qui peuvent prétendre en fait à une
montée prochain match pour les féminines
de montigny-le-bretonneux le 16 octobre
prochain sur le terrain de tôle carantec
une équipe qui compte autant de points
que les yvelinoises dans ce championnat
[Applaudissements]